PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Welcome
to Google Cloud Drawing
Board, where we learn our
way through the cloud.
Today's topic-- what is
Cloud Load Balancing?
This video is divided
into chapters.
Watch the full
video or skip ahead
to any section of your choice.
Sam's new application
has been a hit.
Users are growing across the
world, but Sam is worried.
How would she scale,
optimize, and secure the app,
while keeping the users happy?
That's where Cloud Load
Balancing comes in.
It is a fully-distributed,
software-defined solution
that balances user traffic
to multiple backends
to avoid congestion
and ensure low latency.
There are different
types of load balancing,
depending on the type of
traffic you are dealing with,
global or regional.
Let's understand these
options with a use case.
Say you have user
Shen in California.
You deploy your backend
instances in that region
and configure a
load-balancing virtual IP.
When your new users
grow to another region,
all you need to do is
to create instances
in the additional regions.
There is no change in the
virtual IP or the DNS service
settings.
As your app grows global,
the same pattern can follow.
You see that Maya
from India is routed
to the instances in India.
Now, if the instances
in India are overloaded
and are autoscaling
to handle the load,
that user will
seamlessly be redirected
to the other instance
in the meantime,
and routed back to
India when instances
have scaled sufficiently
to handle that load.
We just saw that
Cloud Load Balancing
uses anycast virtual IPs, giving
you a single global frontend
virtual IP address.
It also provides cross-regional
failover, fast autoscaling,
and scales to millions
of queries per second.
That is external load
balancing at layer 7.
But in any three-tier
app, after the frontend,
you have the middleware
and the data sources
to interact with in order
to fulfill a user's request.
That's where you need
layer 4, internal load
balancing between the frontend
and the other internal tiers.
Layer 4 internal load balancing
is really for TCP/UDP traffic
behind RFC 1918 VIP, where
the client IP is preserved.
You'll get the
automatic health checks,
and there's really
no middle proxy.
It leverages the
software-defined networking
controls and data plane
for load balancing.
Now let's see how the data
model for Cloud Load Balancing
actually works.
For global HTTPS
load balancing, you
have the global anycast
virtual IPs, IPv4 or IPv6,
associated with the forwarding
rule, which directs traffic
to a target proxy.
The target proxy terminates
the client's session.
And for HTTPS, you deploy
your certificates here.
This is not a single device,
but distributed logic
throughout the infrastructure.
The URL map configured
provides layer 7 routing
and directs the client request
to the appropriate backend
service.
The backend services can
be managed instance groups
or network endpoint groups for
your containerized workloads.
This is also where service
capacity and health
is determined, and Cloud CDN
is enabled to cache content
for improved performance.
You can set up firewall
rules to control traffic
to and from your backend here.
Internal load balancing
setup works the same way.
We still have a forwarding rule,
but here, it points directly
to a backend service.
The forwarding rule has the
virtual IP address, protocol,
and up to five ports.
Now, security-- as
a best practice,
we encourage you to
run SSL everywhere.
With HTTPS and SSL
proxy load balancing,
you can use
Google-managed certs,
where Google takes care
of the provisioning
and managing the SSL
certificate lifecycle for you.
And Cloud Load Balancing
supports multiple SSL
certificates, as
well, if you wanted
to serve multiple domains using
the same load-balancing IP
address and port.
Global load balancing
absorbs and dissipates
layer 3, 4 volumetric
attacks across Google's
global load-balancing
infrastructure.
Additionally, by
using Cloud Armor,
you can protect against layer 3
to 7 application level attacks.
And by using Identity
Aware Proxy and firewalls,
you can authenticate
and authorize access
to your backends.
How to choose the right
load-balancing option?
For deciding which
load-balancing option is right
for you, consider factors such
as internal versus external,
global versus regional,
type of traffic--
HTTPS, TLS, UDP.
And based on these
factors, decide
which one is right for you.
If you are looking to reduce
latency, improve performance,
security, and optimize cost
for your backend systems,
then check out Cloud
Load Balancing.
It is easy to deploy in just a
few clicks, set up the frontend
and backends associated
with the global VIPs,
and you're good to go.
Want to learn more?
Check out
cloud.google.com/loadbalancing.
[MUSIC PLAYING]